Columbus Blue Jackets couldn't control it Thomas
hurdle now trying to get it back for the white
plat team McDavid and barzel had it deflect over
the net the poster knock and it's picked off and
skated the other way by Clayton Keller Morgan
Riley played it ahead Matthew centers and Keller
scores Clayton Keller from the Arizona Coyotes
now to your point about the break and the team
that played most recently yeah they do have an
advantage the the other guys have been sitting
around for almost an hour by the time the
concert finished and their game finished
they waited through the other one the goal Keller
is first of the day from Matthews and Riley the
two Leafs McDavid stopped by Sherin knee Lander
off the feed from tro down low and gracious STK
it Marner looking to see if he has help coming he
does I just stick handled away from two Defenders
now A backand and A save made by bosski snatch
out of the air by bosski that's the quick shot
by forsberg made that look pretty easy sure
did hurdle denied by shurin rosi snaps it as
if to say is that all you have Suzuki finds the
trailing Jenner he scored in the opener he scores
again the captain of the Blue Jackets in his
first Allstar Weekend in his 11th season has
now scored in each game VOR shurin he's got
plenty of time to Tee It Up and the shot is
perfect it's 1-1 all right Emily thank you here's
poster knock with McDavid stop by shurkin that's
twice in around the boards for Reinhardt
stay in right along the line good passing
and they hit the post oh beautiful
setup by Rasmus Dalene and a great
chance to take the lead but it was
Reinhardt who hit the post for Brett
Thomas Pardon Me Now a centering pass
KN laner it's poked in Mitch [Applause]
Marner it's neander shot that squeaks through
bossk's pads and before Thomas can get there
Marner just swats it into the empty net and
Matthews has a two1 lead again he just delivers
the pucks with such deception so he's got that
big tow hook wedge and so the goalies have a
tough time reading where the Puck's coming is it
going high is it Low Dry Sidle keeps it alive and
then watch him sling this right on the ice Pasa
sterkin and pasta's got another one the 2020
allstar game MVP one of four in Bruins history
here's Matthews and he scores in the blanket an
ey that's a
beauty two goals 5 Seconds Apart leads
the league with 40 K threads it through
and dry cidal can't knock it out of
the air kind of cool these lines are
staying on the ice we'll see if they
can get a third one in 20 seconds as
Matthews protects the puck a little bit
and then goes right up over the arm of
barosi and here's McDavid the other Captain
throws it right out in front dry Sidle scores
just Starin went sprawling out got a piece
of the puck for a second but dry Sidle stayed
with it and they're tied at three three
goals in 18 seconds in the ice too they
might score four times each this ship McDavid
around the back and dry Sidle loses it for a
second but he's able to catch up to it was 1-1
a minute ago wasn't it these six skaters have
all been out there for a total of 23 seconds
they' been on for three goals K slipped down
along the near boards Robert Thomas it's a
three on0 Thomas off the poster knock stop
final six seconds they need a shot they're
going to get a good shot and a save by bab
rosi tie game 33 as we enter the second
half of the championship final one of
the reasons it is is Sergey brosi makes
this unbelievable save on Mitch Marner at
the buzzer at the end of the first half
marner's had enough of bok's brilliance
be the leading candidate right now to win
the vzna trophy again Jake ainger from the
Dallas Stars in net now for team Matthews
was a high draft choice by Austin Matthews
forsberg [Applause] [Music] scores what a day
for Philip forsberg in his second allstar game
and the first one was way back in 2015 told
guys he's got a a long stick so he can hang
on to the release and freeze the goal tender
helu's back he's sort of half protected in
case he goes across on Clayton Keller two on one
the other way here's Jenner and he's denied by
AER up and down they go two on one k Matthews and
he scores look like he bed that out of midair got
it just on the bounce Jim Montgomery celebrates a
TW goal lead he's trying to be the winning coach
at the allstar game for the second year in a row
breaks out there's zero chance Clayton Keller's
not passing this to Austin Matthews here's the
problem with an allstar game if you're looking
for a checker to defend the lead while you don't
have one Al to Brink it took it away from McDavid
and scored Alex to br Dr it might have cemented
it for team Matthews and might have cemented his
MVP candidacy now the cat gets his stick on the
puck here and now he's got a freebie from the Blue
Line you're not going to miss that as McDavid
wants to get around to the outside and it's oh
just off his stick off his foot as McDavid tried
to kick it up but the Brinks got it and it's now
63 m David personality as well here's hurdle
and he scores the team McDavid refusing to go
[Music] quietly a lower body injury lately
missed the Sharks last two games manages to
put one home there to get them back within
two not much fun in San Jose this year as
they're rebuilding and just been decimated
by injuries but from hurdle gets a chance
out there with dry Sidle and poster knock
they do have the goalie back in for the
moment even with the puck in the offensive
end it's a good thing cuz here's a two
on0 and they score to Brink it with the chance
for another goal passed it up and barzel gets
his first of the day to go with five assists
star game for the New York Islanders see hellu
with pointing to the open side he's like
oh shoot it over here but they made three
more passes and what a terrific job gray
Toronto has done hosting you could feel
the buzz here all weekend this is a city that
loves hockey one of the great cities in North
America and it has been a fantastic weekend
for Toronto and for the National Hockey League